this is for you local artists and
upcoming artists
please do not rush to get your jewelry
i don't want to throw your favorite
rapper under the bus i'm not sure who
your favorite rapper is if it's not me
cool but a lot of these rappers your
jewelry is horrible
i'm sorry it don't hit the way it's
supposed to
gq was good i'm the one and only j out
of dawn and you're watching
on the rocks
out of all the pieces this piece is
special because this was the first
piece of jewelry i got this is a cuban
link iced out
gold and i got this last year around
october-ish
december-ish before i sign my deal it's
like a mandatory piece but to an extent
because it's not flashy but like
i can't wear it everywhere you know like
there's certain occasions where i could
wear it
clark kent has the cape the superman
cape batman has his cape
you feel me i feel like this is
definitely like my cape this is my first
piece of jewelry
and that's crazy this was probably
around like 30 000.
[Music]
this piece right here i gotta kiss it
real quick that's how true it is
this is important because i'm a heavy
believer in the man above
as you can see i got jesus that's what
they call this piece of jesus piece
for those who don't know it's dope
because it has an iced out rope and came
with a iced out rope there's not a lot
of people with iced out ropes especially
with their jesus piece and then their
ice that rope doesn't look like this on
top of that
people get jesus pieces and then they'll
get it they'll put it with a cuban or
they'll just put it with the wrong
chain you know so i felt like the the
rope chain and then the iced out rope
chain at that kind of like tied
everything together
this is definitely the big hornet piece
one of this my favorite for sure
it's just very expensive as far as
quality goes and
as far as meaning goes with me 60 000 by
the way
this piece this is more of like an
everyday piece i wear to go to sleep i
want to take a shower i wear when i'm
with your girlfriend
i can wear it whenever i want basically
what i'm trying to say this is the
g-star logo for those who don't know who
g-star is that's my label
that's my management that's the team you
feel me as us versus everybody
and this is the baby pendant i got a
bigger pendant coming it's in the works
it'll be done around
within like the next couple of days i'm
a little mad i wasn't able to have it
for this segment but
it's going gonna be way bigger than this
and crazier i'm gonna put on my cuban
link
[Music]
these are new these two pieces the
bracelet and the chain
i haven't gotten any chains as far as
like white gold
or rose gold as you see all my jewelry
is just like
solid gold iced out this is different
and i'm
excited about it because it's new you
can see like the bullets it's like a
it's a skinny cube and link iced out
and then there's rose gold at the tips
of the bullets this is crazy
aviani did it number one in the world
right now navioni trust
they got me looking crazy right now
amazing like i make sure that a majority
of my pieces
are from aviani and naviani we trust
that's the slogan for those who that
don't know stay with me one more time
and aviani
we trust
let me show you my my rings i'm a big
fan of the rings
so these two rings when i first put down
money on jewelry these were like the
first pieces i got i got another ring
with this
i had gotten three total rings in that
cuban link the first cooper link i just
showed you guys
and these two pieces have stood with me
up until now
the other piece i'm not gonna lie
destroyed that piece and it has gone
through hell and back and the crazy
thing is i had that that ring on my hand
for like maybe
two or three months and it didn't come
off these two rings now this is where i
upload the game like i really step it up
a bit this is the big step of pieces
there's a difference between artists
having these rings and the artists have
in these wings
i'ma break down the difference for
example as you see
the diamonds end right here at the top
not iced out all around and even if it
was iced out all around
i don't want to knock those rings
because you feel me i got to be humble
about where i came from but they're just
not these rings
these are championship rings you
understand me when you survive the
trenches when you do things people told
you that you couldn't do when you do the
impossible basically
you get rings like this and you put them
on your finger this was the first ring i
had gotten before this one this was like
the championship ring
i love this ring this ring is like the
big step but this is like my
conversation with you is going to be
legendary and cloth talk because i had
this ring on my finger
this was also the price of an ap a lot
of y'all rappers got watches on your
wrist and you
brag about it this ring costs more than
that 50 000
but we're not talking about prices we're
talking about quality over here
and that's it that's my jewelry
collection up until i get more pieces
i was glad i could show you what i got
long story short just invest your money
in the right pieces you feel me
make sure the pieces hit and in general
just make sure you go to aviani